hello and welcome to 3abn today Bible q
a program it's Bible question and answer
we're so glad that you've joined us
today thank you so much for being a part
of our family and thank you for your
prayers and financial support for this
ministry your ministry God's Ministry
3abn it's because of you that we're able
to reach the entire world and you know
what this is just a really fun program
why is that well we kind of get to
interact with you you all send in so
many great questions and comments for
this program we've been inundated may I
say and that's a good thing because
you're very interested in studying the
word of God and you may say well how do
I submit my question for a future
program well there are a number of ways
that you can do that we'll start with
the phone number you can always call us
at
618-627-4651 you can reach out to the
call center they'll send the question
over here you can also text your
question or comment to
618-228-3975 we also have a way that you
can do it through Instagram gotta look
at my notes to make sure I get it right
it's 3abn underscore official and we're
always glad to receive your questions
and comments here for the program and
we'll answer them by God's grace in some
upcoming programs you know today on the
set I feel like I'm surrounded by the
books of the Bible where we're going to
be opening the word of God yes but I
have on the set with me three gentlemen
that have their names are from the Bible
I have Pastor John Wilma McCain so good
to have you on with us today yes I'm
always excited about being able to
identify with the Apostle John John the
Revelator that's right brings me great
joy to know that the lord loves me as
much as he loved them amen and sitting
next to you is Daniel Perrin Daniel book
from the Bible but it's so good to have
you on with us yes it is I want to stand
firm as my name's sake amen yeah dare to
be a Daniel there's that song that we
sang in Sabbath school and vacation
bible school anyway sitting next to you
is Pastor James Rafferty so good to have
you with us today good to be here Greg
it's always a blessing to be part of the
Q a amen what's happened in your life
Pastor James how's the Lord bless you
you well we have been blessed in so many
different ways one of the newest
blessings for us is we have a new new
Dix a new place right we're staying here
at 3abn little apartment uh it's uh
great in its location we can actually
walk over to the studios and it's
surrounded by Green Pastures and
beautiful trees and a little bit quieter
you know with all the coming and going
that we used to have in a little
apartment we were at so it's a real
blessing real blessing amen yeah and I
don't know if people realize this the
how the working arrangement is here he's
a full-time he and his wife employees of
three ABN but they also live in
California so they come and go quite a
bit you live here at 3abn quite a bit so
this Arrangement here you're talking
about it's a blessing have you so close
by man uh Daniel you're in pastoral
department and I know that some people
may not quite know you and your family
you guys arrived a few months ago and it
was a faith Journey your story kind of
reminds me of like Abraham in the Bible
God called you to Southern Illinois you
weren't exactly sure exactly where you
were going God LED you here to 3abn and
what an incredible blessing you and your
family are to the ministry but tell our
folks at home a little bit about your
family because it's you and your wife
plus some children uh yes indeed I have
a wonderful wife who manages a home five
kids age right now eight to sixteen and
the blessing of that is that we get a
front row seat to see exactly how God is
working in people's lives and it it
convinces me that whoever is out there
watching on this TV screen God has God
has a work that he's doing in your life
and I know it's true amen and I should
probably call you Professor Daniel
because you spent 18 years actually
teaching Bible in our seventh Avenue
schools yeah and enjoyed every minute of
I'm sure that's right you know there's
always challenges yeah well teaching the
word of God is always a blessing yeah
amen Pastor John I know that not long
ago it was this is to me just again
confirmation from God but the Adventist
Church of course recognized you and your
wife for your many years 30 plus years
of ministry in the Adventist Church and
you think about all those years Pastor
John how they've gone by I'm sure pretty
quick yeah they've had their challenges
but to minister for the Lord can't go
wrong can you yeah at a pastor's meeting
they had recently gave us they did I'm
not 35 years now it's wow amazing to
think that heading toward 40. from
heading towards 40. don't say that too
loud okay yeah but ordination in 1995
started in 1987. and here it is it's
just when you are loving what you're
doing the time just goes by quickly amen
and uh and then 39 beautiful years of
man marriage really makes the difference
thank you for your years of service too
yes Awards work we've been here since
2003.
isn't that something how time flies
let's start with the word of prayer
before we open the word of God and
answer some of these questions Pastor
John please yes loving father in Heaven
it always is a responsibility as well as
a blessing to be able to open the word
of God we do ask as we open this Lord
that you will now give us the oxygen
tanks we need to survive in this deep
ocean of knowledge that's divinely born
so guide our minds and hearts today as
we answer help us to always desire to
uplift you and give the glory to you
alone in Jesus name we pray amen amen
amen amen thank you so much Pastor John
let's start with you on this question
here from Bart
says Please interpret Luke Chapter 20
verses 34 through 38. yes thank you Greg
and thank you Bart for that question the
whole context of the story about the
Sadducees is verses 27 all the way down
to verses 40 and you'll find that Luke
rarely talks about the Sadducees but as
is the case they will always trying to
find a way to trap Jesus there were two
issues the Sadducees had first in Luke
chapter 20 verse 27 the Bible says then
some of the Sadducees who denied that
there is a resurrection came to him
asking so in the very initial outset
there was a denial about the
resurrection and then Dr Luke in Acts
chapter 23 verse 8 also brings out
another aspect okay for the Sadducees
says there that there is no resurrection
and no angel or Spirit but the Pharisees
confess both so these issues the
Sadducees didn't believe in angels did
not believe in the resurrection so they
tried to trap Jesus with a scenario
where he says in the resurrection they
want to see if he even would even allude
to the fact that the resurrection so
they bring the scenario out that really
has nothing to do with marriage that's
right but it was a very clever
legalistic way of trying to trap Christ
and we read in verse 27 to 33. then some
of the Sadducees who deny that there's a
resurrection came to him asking and they
bring the scenario then they brought out
the teacher they revered the most Moses
and they bring about the because the the
logistical tradition is if a man dies
the brother and the other brother and
the other brother and the other brother
and they all marry the wife taking up
the responsibility of caring for the
family
and then he says now in the resurrection
whose wife is she
so Jesus uses Moses as reference since
the Sadducees revered Moses and he
responds in verses 34 to 38. Jesus
answered and said to them the sons of
this age marry and are given in marriage
but those who are counted worthy of
attaining that age
and the resurrection from the dead he
made a very clear neither married nor
are given in marriage nor can they die
any more for they are equal to the
angels so he said I believe in angels
and I believe in the resurrection amen
and then he goes further down and he
brings Moses into the scenario when you
go down to the fact that Moses brought
the revered uh images or the people of
his lineage into uh focus when he says
verse 37 but even Moses showed in the
burning bush passage that the dead are
raised so he said you believe me or you
believe Moses we both agree so the
Sadducees were saying well what about
that so this really was the question but
there was something that Jesus brought
out that allowed to end this question
with he says
in heaven they're neither marrying nor
giving in marriage but like angels and
so it's obvious that Jesus alluded to a
higher state that we're going to arrive
at which is even better than marriage
and if there's something better than
marriage I'm looking forward to enjoying
that with my wife amen
thank you so very much and thank you
Bart for that question and thank you
Pastor John for the explanation uh
Professor Daniel like that this comes
from the United Kingdom and the person's
name is gray and kind of a long question
here but really good
I've been diagnosed I've recently been
diagnosed with an autoimmune disease and
while it's been a struggle to come to
terms with my condition and disability I
have been reassured by second
Corinthians chapter 12 verses 7 through
10. I've recently felt a pull from the
spirit to use the thorn in my flesh to
exalt God but being introverted I can't
imagine myself doing Evangelistic work I
feel God urging me to use my condition
to reach people in a similar position as
me to serve in spreading his gospel but
I don't know what to do can I please
have some advice all right let me start
by saying what a blessing it is to hear
that you want to use whatever
circumstance you're in to serve God and
we love hearing reports like this and I
think a lot of people are in your
situation and you you mentioned that
text in second Corinthians 12 where Paul
had pleaded with God three times to
remove a thorn in his flesh a physical
ailment we believe in God's response to
him is this in second Corinthians 12 9
it says my grace is sufficient for you
my power is made perfect in your
weakness therefore most gladly will I
rather boast in my infirmities that the
power of Christ May rest on me all right
easy for an extrovert to boast you might
say that's talking that's putting
yourself out there but what about an
introvert how can an introvert serve God
and a lot of people are introverts
statistics say anywhere from a third to
a half of people including myself and
maybe some people at this table I don't
know and that reflects a valuable part
of what God made you to be and being an
introvert though may present some
challenges in reaching out but it still
does not exempt us from the Great
Commission Jesus did not make any
distinction for personality types when
he said things like this in John 13 34
it says a new commandment I give you to
love one another and and that means even
if it doesn't come naturally even if
it's difficult first Peter 4 verse 10 as
each one has received a gift Minister it
to one another and so you need to
identify that God has given you
spiritual gifts strengths even in the
midst of your weaknesses and uh and
whenever you are willing to submit
yourself to God's leading and the
filling of the spirit God will use you
in a way that will be powerful so since
you're feeling this urging to reach out
to people uh in a way I I want to share
a little bit of advice and the first bit
of advice is to put it before God in
prayer and maybe invite somebody in your
life who will pray for you as well to
give you some insight so start there and
then open your eyes and and say God I
want you to lead me into opportunities
that I may not have chosen on my own and
say Lord show me what those
opportunities might be and God will
reveal those moments to you and then I
would say learn to share your testimony
uh and maybe a little bit of a short
gospel presentation and practice it
especially with people you love who are
going to be easy on you but once you
learn how to talk about your experience
with Jesus it becomes easier when God
gives you those opportunities and then I
would say keep a little bit of
literature on hand sometimes maybe you
don't feel like you have the right words
but you can put into somebody's hand
those right words that you have that
have been meaningful to you and so then
rededicate your life and say Lord I want
to be used even if it's outside of my
comfort zone people throughout Christian
history in the Bible certainly were put
outside of their comfort zone and God
will use you in the same way thank you
so very much Daniel very encouraging and
also I want to mention touching on the
resources you're talking about
literature handing it out I want to
encourage you to call the call center
you can see the number on the bottom of
your screen right now
618-627-4651 you can call during regular
business hours you can also go online
and we have all kinds of resources that
we'd be happy to talk to you about we've
got the literature you can hand out DVDs
and see CDs as well all about evangelism
Pastor James let's go to this question
this comes from Houston Texas from Fran
please explain the story in judges 19
verses 28-30 and about Lots offering his
daughter to the men of Sodom it seems
they had little or no regard for their
daughters how could they be considered
righteous in God's eyes well the first
thing we want to note in this question
from Fran Fran great question very
challenging question is that righteous
men do not always act righteously okay
the Bible does call lot a righteous man
for example and at the same time lot was
selfish you know he chose the best
grazing ground over Abraham who really
was his senior and he also hesitated
when the Angels told him leave Sodom and
gomor he hesitated and that's really why
his wife was turned into a pillar of
salt we another example is Abraham
Abraham lied about his wife being his
sister twice causing her almost to be
taken to Wife by other men if God hadn't
interposed and we see uh Isaac doing the
same thing that his father did I mean
he's kind of following his example
um David was a man after God's Own Heart
yet he occasioned the death of the
priests of Nob by trying to save himself
through lying and on another occasion he
coveted and slept with another man's
wife Bathsheba and then had him murdered
to cover up his tracks and yet Abraham
Jacob and Isaac are the foundational
Patriarchs of Israel and again David was
a man after God's Own Heart so it's
really important for us to recognize
that even when God calls men righteous
they don't always act righteously next
we need to consider that in this story
it involves the story of the concubine
in judges 19 involves an immoral woman
she was playing the Harlot
um from her husband she
slept with another man and of course the
death decree uh was due her she was
supposed to die you know under normal
circumstances but her husband this Godly
priest this levite sought to reckon be
reconciled with her and to forgive her
and of course he was bringing her back
to him in the context of this story but
then a third approach we need to look at
in both stories is to understand that
God wants us to trust him no matter what
happens in our lives and in our
situations and we see this over and over
again like for example with the story of
hananiah Michelle and and Azariah you
know they trusted God even though the
king threatened to throw them into the
burning fiery furnace that's right and
we see this over and over again in the
New Testament you know a lot did offer
his daughters to the men of Sodom but
the angels interposed and protected them
and we see Abraham lying about his wife
and she goes to another man twice but
the God interposes and protects her same
thing happens with Isaac
so what about this concubine well
um she was not protected like the
daughter of the man of the house was
and we don't know always why these
things happen we have to put some of
these questions in God's hands we do
know this that God does deliver Justice
to the men of bail and we know also that
in the big picture we see a type if you
will of God's people playing the Harlot
you know Isaiah Jeremiah Ezekiel all
talk about God's people playing the
Harlot as a people they're liking it to
a woman that plays the Harlot and we
know that God allows judgments to come
from the Assyrians and the Babylonians
and if you look read some of the verses
for example Jeremiah 12 7 talks about
God giving his beloved his dearly
beloved into the hands of her enemies
and then it talks about the women of
Zion being ravaged and the children
being dashed to pieces in Lamentations 5
11 and in Isaiah 13 verse 16 and then
God asks people why they're doing things
that cause him to bring these judgments
upon them and then he brings them to a
place of repentance so they turn back to
him you know Matthew Henry's commentary
mentions concerning this adulterous
woman that she fell down at the door
with her hands on the threshold begging
pardon as it were for a form of
transgression in a posture of a penitent
with her mouth in the dust as she
expired so this hope for us in all these
judgments God is leading us to a place
where we finally acknowledge and repent
and are reconciled to him amen thank you
so very much Pastor James and I like
that too there's always hope right amen
yeah praise the Lord Pastor John let's
go to another Old Testament question
here this one comes from Neil
in Canada says can you please explain
Hosea chapter 1 verse 2. did God
actually ask Hosea to marry a prostitute
wow this is a perfect segue from what
James just talked about the book of
Hosea is a book of an example of a young
man wanting to get married and God says
call Mary Gomer a prostitute now what's
that what's interesting about the story
is
that the Lord knew before
Goma messed up that she was going to
mess up and when you look at and follow
through the examples of the stories in
the book of Hosea this is a continual
example of the unfaithfulness of the
people of God
so you find I'll go to Jeremiah 3 verse
14 to lay the foundation so this is an
actual this is not an allegorical
statement but this is an actual account
and when you look at the stories each of
the names
indicate the Journey of the children of
Israel with God for example the first
child meant God sows the second one
meant no mercy in this house the third
one meant not my child and that's when
Gomer left but Hosea pursued Gomer and
you find in Hosea 2 verse 5 to 7.
for their mother has played the Harlot
so these three children are mentioned
showing that it's an actual woman they
wouldn't be mentioning children's names
if they were not actual children that
were conceived between Hosea and Gomer
she who conceived them has behaved
shamefully for she said I will go after
my lovers who gave me my bread and my
water my wall and my linen my oil and my
drink therefore behold I will hedge up
your way with thorns and wall her in so
that she cannot find her pets this is a
beautiful story of how when we go astray
the Lord doesn't Force us to come back
but he makes our journey difficult and I
love this it goes on it says um verse 7
of Hosea 2 she will chase her lovers but
not overtake them yes she will seek them
but not find them then she will say I
will go and return to my first husband
for then it was better for me than now
and that's why the Book of Revelation
says we have lost our first love the
same thing that's happening to Israel
that happened in the life of Goma and
Hosea is happening today you have lost
your first Love Therefore repent in
verse 4 chapter 4 verse 15 of Hosea we
read these words
though you Israel played the Harlot let
not Judah offend do not come up to
gilgal nor go up to Beth Haven nor swear
an oath saying as the Lord lives so this
is just a beautiful story where
sometimes the Lord may ask us to do
something that seems completely out of
ordinary and I like to give some
imaginary context to to uh Hosea okay
can you imagine a young man entering a
seminary single at Andrews University
Laura says you know there's a lady
that's not on the campus
she's the neighborhood prostitute she
needed to be your wife and he says
excuse me Lord that's how God sees the
unfaithfulness of his people but he
loves us and brings us back into
relationship when we come back to our
first love amen thank you so very much
Pastor very good very well explained
Daniel let's go to our home state here
this question it says from no name but
it says viewer from Illinois are there
three Heavens I'm a year and a half into
being a Seventh-Day Adventist and wanted
to know if that's true all right I am so
glad that you're learning and growing
and asking good questions here Paul uses
this phrase the third heaven in second
Corinthians 12 and without looking at
the context or taking into account what
the rest of scripture says it's easy to
maybe come to a wrong conclusion in
thinking that there are different levels
different degrees of reward in heaven
but Paul says here he's continuing his
section from chapter 11 where he was
describing his apostleship so he's
sharing his experience he says in
chapter 12 verse 1 it is doubtless not
profitable for me to boast not wanting
to boast here says I will come to
visions and Revelations of the Lord I
Know a Man in Christ who 14 years ago
whether in the body I do not know or
whether out of the body I do not know
God knows such a one was caught up to
the third heaven and there's that phrase
and then down in verse 4 says how he was
caught up into paradise and heard
inexpressible Words which it is not
lawful for a man to utter of such a one
I will not boast yet of myself I will
boast in my infirmities so he doesn't
want to boast in himself but sharing his
experience here and uh so what does the
word heaven mean I'll share with you
three Old Testament texts but we can
find these in the New Testament as well
Isaiah 55 verse 10 says for as the rain
comes down and the snow from heaven and
do not return there but water the Earth
and so this speaks of heaven where the
clouds are this is our atmosphere this
is where you and I breathe the air and
NASA tells us that this atmosphere that
we're in extends 62 miles up into the
air and so that's that is one way the
Bible uses heaven Psalm 8 verse 3 says
when I consider your Heavens the work of
your fingers the moon and the stars
which you have ordained and so this is
the expanse of space this is where the
planets and stars things outside of our
atmosphere are and maybe you're one who
enjoys looking at that through a
telescope uh Psalm 33 verses 13 and 14
says the Lord looks from Heaven he sees
all the sons of men from the dwelt place
of his dwelling he looks on the
inhabitants of the earth and so this
would be the third heaven this is God's
dwelling this is the paradise that he
promises to us and so we see three
Heavens here we have a first Heaven our
atmosphere a second heaven this uh the
expanse of space and the third heaven
God's very dwelling Deuteronomy chapter
10 verse 14 is one place among several
that mentions all three of these that
speaks of Heaven the highest heavens and
the Earth and all that is in it
including its atmosphere and then we
read about Jesus they're in Ephesians 4
10 it says he ascends ended up far above
all the heavens and so Jesus goes
through the atmosphere into space into
the very dwelling of God now you and I
are in this atmosphere here the first
heaven we can see the second heaven but
one day like Jesus we will be led up far
above all Heavens into the very Dwelling
Place of God so that's the three Heavens
the third heaven amen amen yeah thank
you very much Daniel very well explained
Pastor James this question comes from
Lisa what scripture references do you
use to support the teachings on
investigative judgment great question
Lisa there are a number of verses that
we can look at I'll give you some
references here that you can write down
and are the viewers who are interested
in this question First Peter chapter 4
verse 7 the time has come the judgments
begin at the house of God oh verse 17
first Peter 4 17. Matthew chapter 12
verses 36 and 37 Jesus there is talking
about that every word that we speak will
have to give an account thereof in the
day of judgment and then Ecclesiastes 12
verses 13 and 14 tell us that the
conclusion of the whole matter is to
fear God and keep his Commandments
because God is going to bring every work
whether it's good or evil into judgment
and then there's these verses in the
Psalms we take the phrase investigative
from the Bible itself in Psalm 11 verse
4 Psalm 26 verse verse 2 Psalm 139 23-24
and even Jeremiah 17 verse 10 there is a
word used there that in its root in the
Hebrew means to investigate to test or
to investigate test me try me
investigate me and these verses are all
describing the call of individuals and
believers
they're requesting God to investigate
them to try them in a sense to see if
there's any wicked way in them and to
lead them in the way Everlasting so
God's people have never been afraid of
Judgment of Investigation because they
put their trust in Jesus Christ for
their righteousness and they want God to
reveal to them anything that's out of
harmony with Jesus Christ so that that
can be exposed and given to Jesus and
forgiven and they can stand according to
Matthew 22 11-14 as guests in the
wedding that are covered with the
Garment of Christ's righteousness and
not their own righteousness another
important aspect to this is why is there
an investigative judgment and there are
three reasons Romans 14 says that God
has an investigative judgment so that we
will stop judging one another we're all
going to stand before the adjustment
seat of Christ so we don't need to judge
one another anymore right number two
Matthew 27 21-23 says there are many
people who profess to be Christians but
aren't right they're they're actually
just professors now remember remember we
can't judge according to Romans 14. but
Matthew 27 21-23 tells us there are many
people who who rely upon their good
works and not upon the righteousness of
Jesus Christ who say we've done many
wonderful things in thy name and Jesus
says well I don't know you you don't
know me you are not relying upon my
righteousness you relying upon your work
so that tells us we can't rely upon our
good works for our salvation and then
number three Revelation chapter 12 verse
10 tells us we have an accuser of the
Brethren Zechariah 3 also describes him
as the one who accuses us before God day
and night and Jesus wants to silence
those accusations and so he's going to
allow every work to be brought up so he
can rebuke Satan and say these have been
redeemed by my blood by my righteousness
the Lord of Yuki Satan even the Lord
amen thank you so very much Pastor James
great references and good question on
the investigative judgment as well I
want to encourage you to check out three
ABN plus dot TV you may say well why do
I want to do that you want to do it for
several reasons is one of those is that
you can watch this program again in
other previous Bible q a programs the
beautiful thing about three ABM plus is
that you can start playing it you can
pause it write down these references you
can rewind it and then you can play it
again I know these programs go by in a
hurry and I don't know if you keep a
stopwatch as these pastors answer the
questions but they're only given about
three minutes some of the questions
about four so this is a very rapid paced
program and I know it's always hard we
get comments from you saying please have
them slow down give more time where
we're trying to answer as many questions
as we can so check out
3abnplus.tv and if you have some
questions that you would like to submit
for some upcoming programs you can
always do that through texting is one
way and that's
618-228-3975 or you can always email us
at bibleqa at 3abn.tv
Pastor John this is um let's go to this
question here I don't see a name with it
but it's a really good question it says
recently I have heard people saying that
Jesus was created by the father and that
is why he is called begotten they also
say that he isn't God but just the Son
of God this doesn't make sense to me
what do I say to them well let me give
them the answer Jesus is very much a God
and the word begotten doesn't mean
conceived from but simply sent from but
now let's go ahead and walk through the
Bible and let the Bible answer itself
now one of the questions that people
never ask themselves or the statement
that is often not made
Jesus cannot be the Creator
let me rephrase that Jesus cannot be the
Redeemer
if he was created yeah that's correct
the those who are created cannot redeem
the creation that's right only the
Creator can redeem the creation and so
this is something that people that get
into this long drawn-out argument about
words in the Greek and Hebrew forget the
fact that the creation cannot redeem
itself it's only the Creator can do that
so let's go to Genesis 1 1. I'll just
give you some very quick questions some
very quick scriptures in the beginning
God created the heavens and the Earth
well who is that referring to Genesis 1
26 and God said let us make man in our
image according to our likeness so when
you look at that they also fail to bring
into consideration the condescension of
Christ you know there was a Plan of
Redemption
A Plan of Salvation in the event that
man would sin and this called for Jesus
coming into the world he became sin for
us that we might become the
righteousness of God in him that's the
condescension so when he came in human
form he had to face trials and
tribulations just like we couldn't use
his divinity he said in the condescended
form I of my own self can do nothing but
there were instances throughout his
ministry that was very clear that he in
fact is God you find in John chapter 9
verse 35 to 38 when there was a
contention and I'll read the story Jesus
heard that they had cast him out
and when he had found him he said to him
do you believe in the Son of God in
verse 36 of John 9 he he answered and
said who is he Lord that I may believe
in him and Jesus said to him
you have both seen him and it is he who
is talking with you now this is a
powerful point then he said Lord I
believe and he worshiped him only God is
to be worshiped amen but this man right
away worshiped Jesus why would you
worship one who was not God the problem
was only amongst the Pharisees and
Sadducees and scribes and aseans and the
religious leaders about his divinity but
it was never an issue among those who
were not a part of the ruling class and
even the demons knew that he was divine
good point so so they knew that Jesus in
fact is divine matter of fact Psalm 45
verse 6 speaking about God we read your
throne oh God is forever and ever a
scepter of righteousness is the scepter
of your kingdom that's what David Assam
says about God but what does God say
about his son Hebrews 1 8 but to the son
he says quoting the same scripture you
are thrown o goddess forever and ever a
scepter of righteousness is the scepter
of your kingdom so this foreverness of
Jesus is the foreverness of his father
and also the son there is no well I
created you and then you created
everything else that's not what the
Bible says John 1 verse 4 John 1 verse 3
says all things were made through him
and without him nothing was made that
was made including himself nothing was
made Colossians 1 verses 15 to 17 I'll
just go further down it says for by him
or all things created that are in heaven
that are in the earth visible and
invisible whether there be Thrones or
dominions or principalities or Powers
all things were created by Him and for
him and before all and he is before all
things and by him all things exist so if
he's before all things he can't be
before himself because he is the
beginning I'm the alpha and the Omega
amen wow praise the Lord thank you so
much Pastor John four minutes that's not
much time I got a lot more to say yeah
no that was fantastic though thank you
so very much
uh Daniel let's go to actually this one
here on the Fallen Angels it's a it's a
really good question
and uh it comes from duanelle from
California
says do the Fallen Angels have varying
degrees of wickedness some less and some
more in Luke 11 26 seven other Spirits
were more wicked than the original one
good question all right in our heart we
want to know what am I up against what
is my opponent and there's no book in
the Bible called The Book of Angels or
demons and so we have to search and say
God teach us from your word amen and
while we focus we want to know about the
Angels really we want to know about the
power of God that's what we want to know
and so Jesus gives us a glimpse in Luke
11 there verses 24 to 26 I'll read what
it says there when an unclean Spirit
goes out of a man he goes through Dry
places seeking rest and finding none he
says I'll return to my house from which
I came and when he comes he finds it
swept and put in order and then he goes
and takes with him seven other Spirits
more wicked than himself and they enter
and dwell there and the last state of
the man is worse than the first and we
don't want that so first Jesus is
clearly referring to Demons here this
comes right after a section where he's
cast out a demon and he's talked about
Satan as their leader and ruler and the
Bible does confirmed that demons are
Fallen Angels so when you're talking
about Fallen Angels here these are these
are demons so let's just recognize that
Sin is Sin and fallen angels are 100
guilty uh having the same final result
but because these fallen angels are
following their own will and not the
will of God they have varying degrees of
of consequences about what comes from
their actions and temptations varying
forms of evil come from it the point of
this text though here is that God is a
gentleman and Satan is not you have to
invite God into your life and make room
for him Satan on the other hand he will
make himself at home in any heart in any
life that is not decidedly governed by
God
and and Satan's path is one of
escalating evil it will get worse and
worse the more we allow him to have
influence in our life and so the point
here is not so much to teach us about
angels or demons but we do learn about
that here as much as it is to instruct
us on the importance of choosing
decidedly right now to have our lives
filled with the Holy Spirit and we must
invite God in to dwell there and fill
that space within us and so when we ask
the question what am I up against
we recognize that the power of sin is
not broken only by pushing evil actions
out of our lives or evil thoughts out of
our minds the power of sin is broken by
inviting God's presence the Holy Spirit
to be the controlling influence of our
thoughts and actions and so this is what
we mean when we talk about surrendering
your life to God it's not just saying
I'm gonna not do evil things I'm going
to have God dwelling within taking that
space being the one in charge amen and
so if we allow evil influences to return
and control in our lives then there will
be an escalating experience of evil that
will then that will then spill over into
the lives of others and damage us even
more severely and so if we go back
either in the same chapter Luke 11 verse
13. Jesus says if you then being evil
know how to give good gifts to your
children how much more will your
heavenly father give the Holy Spirit to
those who ask him uh repeatedly in this
little section it talks about asking and
so if you have not asked God to fill you
with the Holy Spirit this is something
that we as Christians have to do it's
not an option one of the things we can
add to our Christian Life if we want to
be fully controlled by God and be free
of those other influences we have to ask
God to fill us with the Holy Spirit and
so I just encourage and challenge you to
make that a part of your prayer life
today and every day from here on Amen no
praise the Lord thank you so very much
Daniel
uh Pastor James question here from Upper
Marlboro Maryland from Brian in
Revelation 9 4 John explained that the
locusts were not to harm the grass of
the Earth or any green thing or any tree
but only those men who do not have the
Seal of God on their foreheads what kind
of seal or Mark will men of God have on
their forehead will it be like a tattoo
excellent question uh Brian thank you
for that we read about the Seal of God
in the Book of Revelation there are a
couple of places where the Seal of God
is described to be the character of God
and let me just give you those
references Revelation Chapter 14 verse 1
in Revelation chapter 22 verse 4. now
you may not recognize that word
character because the word that is used
there is name they have the name of God
in their foreheads they will all have
God's name written in their foreheads
that's what we're told in Revelation 14
verse 1 in revelation 22 4 but the word
name is synonymous with character and is
used in the Bible over and over again to
reveal character so when we talk about
name we're talking about God's character
and of course God's character is a
reflection of his Ten Commandment law
which both describe God as a god of love
According To Jesus words in Matthew
chapter 26 verse or 22 verses 36-40
Jesus said says that the first
commandment the greatest commandment is
to love God with all the heart mind and
soul and the second is like unto it to
love our neighbor as ourselves in fact
in first John chapter 4 verse 8 God is
described as love God is love that's his
character that's his name and we are to
be sealed with that character we were
created with that character in the
beginning we were created in the image
of God we had the character of God we
had the love of God that's what we
reflected and we were in harmony with
the law of God but at we as we fell we
lost that character we lost that name
and God wants to restore that name to us
so
the way God seals us with the character
of Love Is by the Holy Spirit the third
person of the godhead and we're told
this in Ephesians chapter 1 verse 13 and
Ephesians chapter 4 verse 30 we're
sealed with the Holy Spirit and that is
what we're talking about here in the
Book of Revelation God's people have
always been sealed they've always been
destined to be sealed with the Holy
Spirit to have the restoration of the
character of God in them a reflection of
God's law in them and in the Book of
Revelation it's going to come to a
pinnacle it's going to come to a final
climax a Zenith if you will where we're
going to see in Revelation 14 God's
people having the Seal of God the name
of God the character of God and the
wicked also being fully manifested fully
manifesting the character of Satan we
see two harvests taking place in the
last part of Revelation chapter 14. so
the protecting seal of God according to
the Book of Revelation according to the
Bible the protecting seal of God is the
name of God the character of God God's
character is love and we are sealed with
God's love through keeping his
Commandments and that's how we are to
love God and love our neighbor and that
seal or character of God is the work of
the holy spirit in us he seals into us
into the truth of the gospel and
according to Exodus chapter 20 in
Revelation 13 and Revelation 14 the
identifying Mark of God's seal in the
last days is going to be the fourth
Commandment specifically the worshiping
of God and the fourth Commandment the
Everlasting gospel calls us to worship
God as Creator in order to be sealed
with his name and to resist the mark of
the beast amen thank you so very much
Pastor James you know it's just
incredible the Bible is so full of
treasures and Nuggets aren't there wow
what a blessing Pastor John we've had a
lot of questions it seems like this
program from the Old Testament about
stories from the Old Testament and this
is one here from Tai from North Carolina
where do I find the story of Balaam the
prophet and the donkey that spoke to him
I did a sermon a number of years ago
that I'm going to resurrect that okay
because you know we have an audience
that would I think will be blessed by
the sermon it was it was entitled Dumb
and Dumber and uh the question was which
one was Dumber the prophet who refused
to listen to God or the donkey that
chose to listen and this is in Numbers
Chapter 22. you start the story starts
actually from verses 21 all the way down
to the very end of the chapter actually
verse 40 you find that the story is
listed there you know Balaam was
uh a prophet of God but balak sent to
Balaam he wanted him to curse the people
of God the children of God and um you
find in verse 21 I'll just share some of
the story with you because the answer is
already given it's in the book of
numbers but listen to this very
interesting story how God shows that to
me the lesson here is amazing God says
we often call animals dumb but who's
Dumber animals who can be trained or my
children who refuse to be trained who's
Dumber an animal who can take commands
and follow them to the T or my children
who refuse to even acknowledge my
commands exist so this is a story about
the whole dilemma of humanity more
specifically of the chosen of God
because there are many leaders today
that are chosen of God that can be
bought and this is a story where he's
bought out by an adversary to do
something that's uh that's anathema to
the very call in his life Balaam decides
to do what God never called him to do
thinking that his position with God will
grant him access to curse the people of
God whom he's called to lead this is
ironic and so this is kind of today
what's happening in our world today
that's why it's important as religious
leaders that the call of God on our
lives is a call that we cannot be bought
from that's good and Ellen White says
that there's a need for men who cannot
be bought cannot be sold there's like
Josh was in Caleb's and Elijah's men who
are as true to God as the needle is to
the north and that was not the case of
the story Balaam decided so the donkey
decides you know what what's that you
wouldn't even listen
so how amazing what's even more ironic
in the story and I encourage you to read
it is not only the donkey talking to
Balaam but Balaam talking to the donkey
yeah I mean like he's having a
conversation with him and the Bible says
in Numbers 22
um
and then God's anger verse 22 was
aroused because he went and the angel of
the Lord took his stand in the way as an
adversary against him and he was riding
on his donkey and his two servants were
with him now verse 20. the donkey saw
the angel of the Lord standing in the
way with a drawn Sword and the donkey
turned aside out of the way and went
into the field and so I think you would
really be encouraged to read the rest of
the story what an amazing story it's in
Numbers chapter 22 and really which one
are we dumb or Dumber
thank you so much Pastor John I think we
have time for uh two more questions here
Daniel this is a good one here the name
who submitted is Prince here's the
question when you read Matthew 6 9-13 it
says do not put us in Temptation I have
been asking myself is it correct or not
because when you go back to Paul First
Corinthians 10 13 says temptation is
normal for human beings and to Jacob
James 1 2 through 12 says it's happiness
so what is Matthew saying all right if
you're facing Temptation today I've got
good news for you that God offers
provision that you can be victorious
over Temptation and sin amen but do we
really have to ask God not to lead us
into temptation is that something God
would do
um James 1 13 they're part of what you
referenced says God does not tempt
anyone to sin all right so we will start
there First Peter 1 16 quoting from
Leviticus he says God tells us to be
holy even as I am Holy so God's desire
is us for to be victorious over sin he
doesn't want to place Us in places where
he knows that we will fail Temptation
certainly is the common experience of
man as you as you reference there and
Jesus shared that experience with us and
was Victorious and we know that when we
Face Temptation by God's power it does
strengthen us and and help us to learn
and to grow so what do we learn from
Jesus's prayer that he shares there that
Matthew Luke record where he says lead
us not into temptation but Deliver Us
from Evil and the first thing is that
this lets us know how we should feel
about Temptation that we as Christians
should make it a point to avoid
Temptation in our life and to recognize
where it might lie and to not willingly
and intentionally Place ourselves there
we should not desire it we should desire
to avoid sin altogether and ask God's
help in them and number two this uh this
prayer that Jesus gives us recognizes
that God is the one leading and we need
to surrender to his will and his plan
and path even if it goes in a direction
maybe that is difficult for us that we
we figured that that it would be harder
for us to go this direction and then we
recognize that since we are following
God hearing this prayer if he's leading
us then he is not going to place us in a
position that we are going to fail in
and we're not facing Temptation alone
since he's leading we have his power his
guarantee that we can be victorious that
he will not give us or allow us to go
through more than we can bear with his
strength and so we see that Temptation
wherever it may lie when we anticipate
it we say Lord you've allowed me to face
this and so I'm claiming right now your
strength and your power God's goal for
us there is at the end of this phrase
where it says Deliver Us from Evil and
so we know that that Deliverance comes
from him and so we can't boast in our
own strength say Lord help me through
this we find this prayer again and we'll
see it one more time here in Psalm 141
verse 3 and 4 set a guard O Lord over my
mouth keep watch over the door of my
lips do not incline my heart to any evil
thing to practice Wicked works with men
who work iniquity and do not let me eat
of their Delicacies Lord I place myself
in your hands and I desire you to lead
me through whatever troubles lie ahead
with your power amen praise the Lord
what hope and encouragement praise the
Lord thank you so very much Pastor James
this question comes from Ann and she
lives in Ooltewah Tennessee if according
to history and according to Adventist
teachings Daniel 7 25 has already been
already fulfilled why should we expect
another big time of trouble as if all
the incredible sufferings of the Dark
Ages were not enough all right very good
question and from Tennessee we're
looking in Matthew 24 and we're
correlating that with Daniel 7 verse 25
it talks here in verse 21 about a Great
Tribulation such as was not since the
beginning of the world to this time nor
ever shall be and except those days
should be short and there should be no
flesh say but for the election sake
those days shall be shortened there is
in the Bible in Bible prophecy a
tribulation a Great Tribulation and then
there is the time of trouble such as
never was
Matthew's gospel here Jesus in Matthew
24 is talking about this Dark Ages
tribulation and the thing about the Dark
Ages tribulation was that 50 to 100
million people they're estimating God's
people Christians Believers were
martyred they lost their lives during
this time that will never be again
that's what we just read such as was not
or ever will be again was not would
compare it to the flood for example
where only eight people were saved but
none of God's people were lost
Shelby is relating to the time of
trouble now the difference between the
Dark Ages tribulation in the time of
trouble is when Michael stands up in
Daniel chapter 12 verse 1 and we can
just read the verse just to make sure it
says at that time Sean Michael stand up
and there shall be a time of trouble
such as never was since there was a
nation even at that time and everyone
shall be delivered every one of thy
people should be delivered who are
written in the book in other words the
time of trouble in in Daniel chapter 12
verse 1 when Michael stands up is a time
of Deliverance for God's people in the
Dark Ages you have 50 to 100 million of
God's people being martyred in the time
of trouble when probation closes and
Michael stands up none of God's people
are martyred so that's the difference
that's why there's two so it's not that
there's going to be another time of
trouble like Daniel 7 25 there's not
going to be another tribulation like the
Dark Ages in Matthew 24 the Great
Tribulation the time of trouble that's
coming is going to be awful it's going
to be terrible but not for God's people
and I say that in a sense because of
course God's people who are sealed are
going to go through that time of trouble
it's going to be difficult but
none of them will lose their lives the
seven last plagues will be poured out
we're told in Revelation 16 and 15 and
16 but none of God's people will receive
any of those plagues amen thank you so
very much Pastor James what we're going
to do right now is actually take a quick
break and we'll be right back with some
closing comments
if you're enjoying our 3abian Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3abian Bible q a for answers from
God's word
these Bible q a programs always go by in
a hurry in the last two minutes we'd
like to do some closing comments or
final thoughts Pastor James let's start
with you and we'll go around the circle
I want to go back to the first question
judges 19 and what was that the
concubine oh yes Lots children girls
um four things I just wanted to
summarize with that because it's a very
difficult question number one was
righteous men do not always make
righteous choices and then number two
God seeks to protect us from the evil of
the unrighteous choices and the right
the choices of righteous men that are
wrong at times and then number three God
eventually has to honor the choices of
all of us and allow us to experience the
consequences and the evil of our choices
because God is gentleman he doesn't
Force us to do what is right and hoping
that we will repent from all of the evil
and then in the end number four God is
going to judge all of those who do evil
amen very good thank you Pastor Daniel
yes thinking about the Fallen Angels who
are back with that question who are
completely controlled by self with no
influence of God and I just I was
thinking it must be awful to be one of
the Fallen Angels they must hate each
other uh to be completely filled with
self and selfishness and I'm just so
thankful that God says I'm gonna I'm
gonna take all of that out of you and
fill you with my spirit of love and
kindness amen praise the Lord thank you
so much yes and speaking of the Lord our
creator Psalms 90 verse 2 before the
mountains were brought forth or even
thou has formed the earth and the world
even from Everlasting to Everlasting
Thou Art God how long is Everlasting I
hope to find out one day amen thank you
so much Pastor John and thank you so
much Pastor James Pastor Daniel Pastor
John for being on today thank you for
your heart for the Lord and for his word
and in closing as you know like to
always read second Timothy 2 15.
study to show thyself approved unto God
a Workman that needeth not to be ashamed
rightly dividing the word of truth thank
you so much God bless you we'll see you
next time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]